you have a degree in script and
psychological analysis yeah I did that
in Montreal that's I didn't I didn't do
the normal film school I think you just
go and do it and you're gonna learn
itself you know I mean and but I always
the the psychoanalysis behind the films
I always think that it's super
interesting to first to create
characters or just to make any film
because I think yeah if it was cool
normal from school like we take the
camera and go do it yourself and it's
gonna be your future film school now so
psychological analysis as it comes to
writing the script you say that you're
not into writing it but you do enjoy
showing yeah so you can show an emotion
you can show someone's displeasure with
something and that the motives behind
that are more interesting to you can you
go yeah exactly and I think knowing
those it's again it goes back to the
symbolism you know for going from
psychoanalysis there's so many symbolism
that you can create that showcase
instead of just working to create that
character this way it's just with
symbolism you can really play to
showcase those threat of personality
from a character and that's that's what
I love and I prefer to do it visually
then just with dialogue or crazy
characters or something like that I
think visually is for me is a more
interesting way to just show it it's not
as it's not as obvious to for some
people to some time to get all the
elements but it's there you just have to
find them I felt that you used music in
an effective way as well so it's not
just the looks because there wasn't that
really much dialogue in the film there
was a lot of back-and-forth in the
fighting but in terms of certain things
you knew exactly what was happening but
not a lot was said again goes with the
fact that you can say so much without
saying it again my style of film is very
delicate in a way that people will love
it
or they're gonna hate it and I know that
it's as soon as you get a signature some
time with David Lynch some people love
him some people hate it so so yeah I
think with visual you can just express
so much emotion that you don't have to
to express with words and I think that's
kind of the screenwriting right
rules like don't don't don't say don't
don't don't tell show or something like
right so so yeah I think visual is just
the best medium to express any kavanah
of emotion in a different way and in the
film I didn't want to be all about
dialogue I wanted to be all about
emotional struggle you mentioned that
you used to watch three to four films a
day as a kid yeah what were some of
those films of what were the directors I
know you mentioned Kubrick before well
wasn't answer so that's so funny because
I hated sports so that's the only thing
I was doing is watching film and I was a
big big fan of 80s movies all the
committee committees I've never my first
real real film was in 95 it was eat of
Michael Mann that was the first film
that was just like whoa it just knocked
me out I was just like dad sit film
because just before it was all about 80s
movies and but I don't want to do
committees I don't care about that it's
fun I love watching but making them not
really but that's why I think the on the
horizon it's very 80s with the music and
the tone the car you know the the Grand
National cars eighties car right the
music is very 80s and so that's my
influence but it was eat in Michael Mann
that was just like whoa I saw something
serious and then I'll always remember it
was 1895 with the music at the end I was
with Moby the song that he did I was
just like wow that's the best song in a
film and then in 2001 with modern driver
David Lynch that's what really show me
mood the signature of a director and
that's what I was just like that's where
I'm starting making movies mm-hmm so do
you feel that the watching of the movies
was way more effective for you in making
them then going and doing the script and
psychological analysis yeah totally
watching it but I've learned so much at
university with psychoanalysis that was
one of the best part of my life and that
it was like when I was young eat Marlin
Drive that was really starting my career
of just I want to do that and then in
psychoanalysis that's where I said now I
want to do that professionally and
that's that's where I realized like it's
so fun to go deep into the characters
and write everything symbolism and data
that's why I've started applying that to
my script and as I
think that's where my shirt hem got
better and it was after the time that
the short from that I don't want to show
anymore you know it's it's after that
part I was just like if I apply that
it's gonna work and that's why I've
really had it symbolism and stuff like
that and it changed me when I were when
I was using those classes it just it's
really affected me do you remember some
of the things that they talked about
that's really interesting like in terms
of this character that you're writing
about our characters because you said
you didn't do too much backstory for
Casey but then you also talked about
your own story with yeah but Eddie
arisin is it's it's me you know and II
ride the fin on the horizon it's totally
me from every character in the film they
are me and so that's why when I was
working with Tyler or sandy I was
talking about my background and they
totally got it because Tyler was Casey
just and so when I explained my
background he says it's me it's me I
totally get it it's me it's miss me so
who cares if you was born in who cares
what matters that you understand their
action and that it's when I place them
into that world to understand what
they're gonna go through and once you
understand that then it was easy so I
don't need to write a back story on
paper sometimes yes if it's not really
connected to me but uh so for example
the next feature film I'm gonna try that
just to see if it's gonna work and but I
know I'm sure some stuff is just gonna
be pure me and when they're gonna care
that that actor I'm gonna have the same
process this is who I am this is what
that person is going through blah blah
blah and then after that go do your own
backstory you know I don't want to be a
dictator they are are they are artists I
want them those actors don't want them
to bring something to the table that I
don't think about I want to be impressed
I want to be surprised
and that's what I think makes a
beautiful collaboration what if a
filmmaker says well I want to make a
movie but it's too close to me so I
don't want to make it I'd rather make it
about somebody else because they don't
want to expose certain parts of
themselves stop being afraid or
something I don't know it's just do it I
think that's that's the whole point of
doing something because even if he's
trying to do something on the left
he's just gonna go back on the right a
little bit I think it's just automatic
no matter what you're writing even if
you don't think about it it's gonna be
you and then if someone that knows you
personally is gonna read it or see the
films that's you even one of my best
friends saw the film and she's like ha
yeah that point is really like really is
like that's you and then so sometimes
you just don't think consciously you
know you don't know what some time
you're writing but then if people knows
you it's always gonna be you no matter
what because you are writing it so you
can you cannot escape it
you